X is a global cryptocurrency exchange
this is Sam bankman freed testifying
before Congress in December 2021. we are
processing about 15 billion dollars per
day of trading volume by then he had
vaulted to celebrity entrepreneur status
as the founder of the cryptocurrency
exchange FTX what's up guys I'm here
with my boy Sam with the help of
celebrities and expensive ad campaigns
FTX is the safest and easiest way to buy
and sell crypto he promoted crypto's
money making potential to the public
you're getting into crypto as safe FDX
and secure with FTX I buy sell and trade
crypto safely bankman freed became a
billionaire in the face of the industry
him and his colleagues had also made a
big impression in political circles
mainly in Washington by throwing around
millions of dollars in donations and
talking a big game about
their plans to do good with charitable
donations and whatnot but then it all
be ledge he illegally used money from
FTX to cover losses at another company
he started a hedge fund called Alameda
research to donate tens of millions of
dollars to politicians and to buy real
estate in the Bahamas where he was
arrested last year then when questions
about the company's financials spurred a
wave of investor withdrawals FTX
collapsed
its name has since been removed from
this Miami sports arena and both
companies have since filed for
bankruptcy losing an estimated 8.9
billion dollars in customer funds Sam
bankman freed has been waiting for his
day in court here in a New York prison
cell a far cry from the Bahamas resort
where he was living prior to his arrest
the judge in the case revoked his 250
million dollar bail and his permission
to live with his parents in the run-up
to the trial saying that bankman freed
had attempted to intimidate a witness
his former girlfriend who also happens
to be the former CEO of Alameda hi can
you guys say some words with the
microphone while his parents both
lawyers have stood behind bankman freed
the former girlfriend and three former
FTX Executives have pleaded guilty three
are reportedly cooperating with
prosecutors bagman freed has said
repeatedly that he didn't intend to
commit fraud to convict him prosecuted
will have to convince the jury that he
knowingly misled his customers Kristin
salumi Al Jazeera New York
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera